the eh-2-zed of isms geocentrism until
the 16th century geocentrism was the
prevailing theory of what the universe
looked like geocentrism is the belief
that the earth our home planet is at the
center of the universe everything else
revolves around us this seemed obvious
to ancient astronomers
after all they observe the Sun and the
moon the planets and the stars to move
across the sky as we go forward through
time just like we do today so this must
mean that the earth is in the center of
it all right wrong
the earliest geocentric models of
ancient Greek philosophers / scientists
last general rounders such as Plato and
Aristotle in the 4th century BC placed a
stationary earth at the center with the
planets and the stars moving around us
on circles or spheres the thing is the
simple geocentric model couldn't quite
explain all that we see when we watch
the skies for a start the planets change
brightness we shouldn't happen if
they're always the same distance from
the earth second the paths of Mars and
Jupiter through the sky sometimes appear
to go backwards for a time which
shouldn't happen if they're travelling
around in these neat little circles
despite this the theory had such a hold
and astronomers were so convinced by it
that they spent hundreds of years making
all sorts of modifications to try and
make the general theory fit and is
needlessly complicated as it now seems
to modern astronomers this version of
the universe proposed by Ptolemy in the
second century was almost universally
accepted for hundreds of years but not
everyone was happy as far back as a 3rd
century BC our exposures of Samos had
suggested that the Sun was in the center
of the universe and in the years that
followed Ptolemies were both European
and Islamic scientists started to
question aspects of his geocentric model
finally in the 16th century Polish
astronomer Copernicus published his
model of the universe which also put the
Sun not the earth at the center of it
all this is known as heliocentrism
and for the first time mainstream
science at night today we know that even
heliocentrism doesn't tell the full
story while the Sun may be at the center
of our solar system there's just one of
over a hundred billion stars in our
Milky Way galaxy which is itself one of
over a hundred billion galaxies in the
observable universe not only do we have
to contend with being just one of
probably countless planets out there
modern cosmology tells us that the earth
and our solar system doesn't even occupy
a special place in the universe and in
fact it turns out that there is no
center to this universe at all rest in
peace geocentrism thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon